It took 30,000 tons of snow and about 500 tons of ice...
...to make the Ice Hotel in Quebec.
These days, about 100,000 people a year will visit the hotel,...
...but about 5,000 have the nerve to spend the entire night.
You'll get complete instructions on what to wear...
...and how to use the extra strength sleeping bag.
A few common areas include crystalline halls, a slide, and a coffee shop.
One of the most stunning aspects of the Ice Hotel is this chapel here.
Some 40 couples got married here this year.
Imagine the wardrobe.
The place where everyone goes is to the Ice Bar,...
...where unique beverages are served up in ice glasses.
It's like being dropped onto the set of a science fiction movie...
...and animated visitors are finding all sorts of ways to keep warm...
...while enjoying the unique ambience.
In the daytime, before the overnight guests check in,...
...visitors can tour all of the rooms.
Many of which are artistically carved along a special theme.
One suite is like a crystal palace...
...and another is called the mermaid room.
All of the ice block beds are covered in a piece of faux fur...
...and a colorful fiber-optic lighting creates a surreal touch.
Open for three months of the year,...
...the enigmatic Ice Hotel is about a forty-minute drive from Quebec City.
For TravelVideo.tv, I'm Bea Broda.